l'opération nettoyage est en branches et
natacha patrie les orages violents de
samedi ont déraciné plusieurs pains qui
se sont abattues sur sa maison mais le
pire a été évité j'attends les
révélateurs le contracteur des
assaillants s'en vient j'ai le goût de
bardot qui s'ennuie un peu plus loin une
autre maison une voiture endommagée ici
le toit d'un cabanon est complètement
démoli une partie de la clôture arrachez
les assurances je sais pas qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont payer ça discute beaucoup
même si ça fait 40 ans qu'on paye nos
assurances
les travailleurs d'hydro québec qui
rétablissent le courant dans cette rue
alors que les résidents commencent à
s'impatienter jeunes tout perdu notre
nourriture puis on trouve ça choquant
dans sa quatrième journée leur comment
se trouvaient sur des sociétés d'état
espérer ce matin rebrancher la grande
majorité de ses clients d'ici la fin de
la soirée mais ce sera probablement plus
long qu'anticipé hydro-québec on les
voit il chante ici
mais travaille à sous-louer hydro québec
on a pas de communication avec eux
beaucoup d'arbres et de branches sont
tombés sur les fils il faut d'abord tout
dégager l'ampleur du travail est immense
on a souvent des arbres sur les lignes
mais là c'est les armes bon ça travaille
en secret à béligneux café poteau on
fait toujours les projections leur
établissement on n'était pas exactement
nous aussi bex humainement parce que
l'expérience que la situation actuelle
rien à voir aller au delà rentiers de le
cpo débrancher du sud y est rond des
équipes travaillent d'arrache-pied entre
temps ses sauveurs la ville a ouvert un
centre communautaire pour les sinistrés
ils peuvent recharger leur appareil
électronique ou encore prendre une
douche j'ai ici pour rechercher tous
nous nos appareils pire
et on distribue aussi de l'eau potable à
ceux qui en ont besoin quand un puits un
puits tankers pas d'électricité pas
d'eau il y à de longues files d'attentes
devant plusieurs stations-service médias
russes progress de la génératrice pour
ce nouveau pas le choix j'ai même pas
premier temps renault lingots c'est la
même histoire dans plusieurs villes
comme val-david sainte-agathe ou encore
mont tremblant
et c'est la même question qui demeure
sur toutes les lèvres n'est qu'un
reviendra le courant
ici olivier bachand radio-canada saint
sauveur